("Funky Hornblower" by Warner
/ Chappell Production Music)
- Alright.
McDonald's rejects Burger
King's McWhopper stunt.
What an (bleep).
- So, Burger King wanted to
be a super nice dude about it
and decided to approach
McDonald's to make a McWhopper.
- "Burger King proposed a day of peace."
I did not know they were at war.
- "McDonald's quickly rejected the idea
"by Wednesday morning."
That's so sad.
Rejection hurts no matter who you are,
even if you're the Burger King.
- I think it's an excellent
idea to mash these things up.
- So what we're gonna do today is,
we're gonna take a Big Mac and
we're gonna take a Whopper,
and we're gonna mush them together,
make the McWhopper that
we were supposed to have.
- So you've got your Whopper here,
which has that perfect charbroiled taste,
you know, they're famous
for, the grill marks.
- The ideal thing you wanna do here
is make sure you don't have
too much bread in one place
and too much meat in one place.
You have to get it nice and even.
- [Voiceover] I'm gonna
keep the middle bun,
just because that's what
makes a Big Mac a Big Mac.
- And then you've got this
cute little friend right here.
- [Voiceover] And we'll take this apart.
- Okay.
- (laughs) It's been McWhoppered.
- I really hope I don't
poop my pants after this.
- Aw, man.
Lord Jesus, I'm sorry for
destroying this vessel
you have created.
- This is what we could
have had, McDonald's.
You ruined this for us.
- Here I go.
- No.
- Oh!
- It's so good.
- Why isn't this a real thing?
- Taste's like carbs.
Love it.
- Messy but delicious.
- It's probably a lot
of calories, but hey,
you're getting double the veggies, so.
- I think if I was really
drunk I would eat this.
- If you, like, drop this off
a roof onto a person's head,
I really actually think
you could do some damage.
It's like four pounds.
- This is a win, right here.